This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I swear to fulfill to the best of my ability and judgment. This covenant. A man must have a code. I don't know. Doubt. The fundamental ethical precept of medicine is that doctors first do no harm. This led the American Medical Association to adopt opinion 2.06
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我发誓尽我最大能力和判断力来履行这个誓言。这个盟约。一个男人必须有自己的准则。我不知道。怀疑。医学的基本伦理原则是医生首先不能作恶。这促使美国医学会在1992年采纳了
of the AMA code of medical ethics in 1992. An individual's opinion of capital punishment is the personal moral decision of that individual, a physician as a member of a profession dedicated to preserving life when there is hope of doing so should not be a participant in a legally authorized execution. It goes on from there. Lawyers have an ethics code, journalists have an ethics code, so it shouldn't surprise you that architects do as well.
美国医学会医学伦理准则第2.06条意见。个人对死刑的看法是个人的道德决定，医生作为致力于在有希望挽救生命时保护生命的职业的一员，不应参与合法授权的执行。情况大致如此。律师有伦理准则，记者有伦理准则，所以建筑师也有伦理准则，这不应该让人感到意外。
The relevant ethical standard from the AIA that we're discussing is ES1.4. Human Rights. that we're discussing is ES1.4 human rights. Members should uphold human rights in all their professional endeavors. A number of architects have taken a stance that there are some buildings that just should not have been built. And they don't just mean the ugly buildings. That by design, they violate standards of human rights. That's our producer Sam Greenspan. He's talking about prisons. Specifically, prisons that keep inmates alone in cells with little to do and with minimal human contact. Inmates have names for these places,
我们正在讨论的美国建筑师学会（AIA）的相关伦理标准是ES1.4“人权”，即我们正在讨论的ES1.4“人权”。会员应在其所有职业活动中维护人权。许多建筑师已经表明立场，认为有些建筑根本就不应该被建造。他们指的不仅仅是那些丑陋的建筑。而是从设计上讲，它们违反了人权标准。那是我们的制作人萨姆·格林斯潘。他在谈论监狱。具体来说，是那些将囚犯单独关押在牢房里、几乎无事可做且与他人几无接触的监狱。囚犯们给这些地方起了名字，
the box or the bing. On the outside, we know them as supermax or the shoe. That's SHU, for security housing unit. Now it's up for debate as to whether or not the shoe is solitary confinement. Reason being, and this is something weird we found while researching the story. There is no legal definition for solitary confinement. The UN doesn't have one, the Department of Justice doesn't have one, and neither does the CDCR, the California Department of Corrections and Rehabilitation, the CDCR
叫做“方盒子”或“禁闭室”。在外面，我们称它们为超级监狱或“鞋子”。也就是SHU，即安全住房单元。现在关于“鞋子”是否属于单独监禁还存在争议。原因在于，这是我们在研究这个故事时发现的一个奇怪现象。法律对单独监禁并没有定义。联合国没有定义，司法部没有定义，加州惩教及康复部（CDCR）也没有定义，CDCR
maintains that no prisoners in California are kept in solitary confinement. They refer to the shoe as a quote, segregation unit. But a number of groups, including Amistigh International and Human Rights Watch, do call the shoe solitary confinement. And there's a lot of controversy surrounding one shoe at a Northern California prison called Pelican Bay. Pelican Bay State prison was designed by San Francisco-based architecture firm KMD. KMD declined to speak to us for this story, but Jim Muller, an architect with KMD who worked on Pelican Bay, did talk with Architect Magazine about the prison. He said, quote, the inmates have no contact with other inmates
坚信加州没有任何囚犯被关在单独监禁室中。他们把“鞋子”称为所谓的“隔离单元”。但包括国际特赦组织和人权观察在内的许多组织确实将“鞋子”称为单独监禁。北加州一所名为鹈鹕湾的监狱里的一个“鞋子”单元引发了大量争议。鹈鹕湾州立监狱是由总部位于旧金山的建筑事务所KMD设计的。KMD拒绝就此事接受我们的采访，但曾参与鹈鹕湾项目的KMD建筑师吉姆·穆勒确实接受了《建筑师杂志》关于该监狱的采访。他说：“引述一下，囚犯们与其他囚犯没有任何接触，
during the vast majority, if not all, of the day. They are only allowed out of their cells for very short periods of time for constitutionally required exercise periods." End quote. Life inside of a shoe means 22 to 23 hours a day inside of a tiny room, 80 or so square feet. Nancy Malaine, a radio reporter with Life of the Law, managed to get access to the
在一天中的绝大部分时间，甚至全部时间都是如此。他们只被允许在极短的时间内离开牢房，进行宪法规定的锻炼。”引述结束。“鞋子”里面的生活意味着一天有22到23个小时待在一个大约80平方英尺的小房间里。南希·马莱恩是《法律的生活》节目的电台记者，她设法进入了
shoe in Pelican-Based-A prison in California. She went inside one of the cells and had an inmate, Robert Luca, describe the room. Basically, the cell, I don't know, was size 6x9 or 6x12, whatever it is. And that's your bunk, your living room, the center of it is your walking area, and two steps to the right is your bathroom, pretty much. The official measurements are actually 7.5x12 feet. It's not a space that's designed to keep you comfortable. But it's not these architectural features
加州鹈鹕湾州立监狱的“鞋子”单元。她走进其中一间牢房，让一名囚犯罗伯特·卢卡描述了这个房间。基本上，这个牢房，我不知道，大小是6x9英尺或者6x12英尺，随便吧。那就是你的床铺，你的起居室，中间是你的活动区域，往右两步就是你的洗手间，差不多就是这样。官方尺寸实际上是7.5x12英尺。这不是一个能让你感到舒适的空间。但并不是这些建筑特征
that concern humanitarian activists and psychiatrists. It's the amount of time many prisoners spend in that cell alone, without any meaningful activity. Long-term solitary confinement, which is either for months or years, or it goes on forever, as at Pelican Bay. Connected with absolute idleness, that is, the individual socially isolated to the extreme, but also has nothing meaningful to do, and this causes human breakdown, this destroys people as human beings. Terry Cooper is a psychiatrist who specializes in forensic work. That is, he's an expert on the intersection of mental health
引起了人道主义活动人士和精神病医生的担忧。而是许多囚犯在没有进行任何有意义活动的情况下，独自在那个牢房里度过的大量时间。长期的单独监禁，持续数月或数年，或者像在鹈鹕湾那样无休止地持续下去。与绝对的无所事事联系在一起，也就是说，个人在社交上被极端孤立，而且也没有任何有意义的事情可做，这会导致人的精神崩溃，这会从根本上摧毁一个人。特里·库珀是一名专注于法医工作的精神病医生。也就是说，他是心理健康
and criminal justice. He served as an expert witness on more than 20 class action lawsuits concerning prison conditions. He says there's a whole litany of effects that solitary can have on a person. Massive free-floating anxiety, paranoid ideas, insomnia, depression, and suicidal thoughts are very prominent. Their eyes are destroyed because if you do not look at a distance for a long length of time, your eye deteriorates. They have concentration and memory problems. And I ask if they read and they'll say no because I can't remember what I read three pages earlier. Mounting anger and they almost universally report
与刑事司法交叉领域的专家。他曾在20多个有关监狱条件的集体诉讼中担任专家证人。他说，单独监禁会对一个人产生一连串的影响。大规模的游离性焦虑、偏执观念、失眠、抑郁和自杀倾向非常明显。他们的视力受到破坏，因为如果你长时间不看远方，视力就会恶化。他们有注意力和记忆力问题。我问他们是否读书，他们会说不，因为我不记得三页前读过的内容。愤怒情绪不断积聚，他们几乎异口同声地表示
that they're terrified that their anger will get out of control. They'll be in more trouble and then they'll have a longer term in solitary. And that's just for a normal stable person. For prisoners with a history of or predisposition to mental illness, solitary can bring on a breakdown.
他们非常害怕自己的愤怒会失控。他们会陷入更多的麻烦，然后在单独监禁中被关更长时间。而这还只是针对一个正常、稳定的人。对于有过精神病史或精神病倾向的囚犯来说，单独监禁可能会导致精神崩溃。
Now again, there is no universally accepted definition of solitary confinement. And life the law reporter Nancy Malayne says that compared to other prisons she has visited, there are actually some good design elements in the Pelican Bay shoe. Inmates can get natural light from skylights outside of their cells, which drifts into the doors made of perforated metal. These porous doors allow for inmates to communicate with each other, even though there are no lines of sight to any prisoner from within the cell.
再次说明，目前对于单独监禁并没有一个普遍接受的定义。《法律的生活》节目记者南希·马莱恩表示，与她参观过的其他监狱相比，鹈鹕湾的“鞋子”单元实际上有一些不错的设计元素。囚犯可以从牢房外的天窗获得自然光，光线透过穿孔金属制成的门散落进来。这些多孔的门允许囚犯互相交流，尽管从牢房内部根本看不到任何其他囚犯。
But on the other hand, cells don't have windows. Inmates never get to see the horizon. The only time prisoners get to leave the cell is to visit the shower or the exercise yard. And the exercise yard is an empty, windowless room, not much bigger than a cell with 20-foot high concrete walls. And while many prisoners in the shoe have a cellmate, Terry Cooper's says sharing a
但另一方面，牢房没有窗户。囚犯永远看不到地平线。囚犯唯一能离开牢房的时候就是去淋浴或去运动场。而运动场是一个空荡荡的、没有窗户的房间，比一个带有20英尺高混凝土墙的牢房大不了多少。虽然“鞋子”里的许多囚犯都有狱友，但特里·库珀表示，合住一个
cell is often worse than being alone. So if that's not solitary confinement per se, you could call it a kind of binary confinement. And all of this taken together, some people call torture. In 2011, Juan Mendes, the UN Special Rapper Tour on Torture, said anything over 15 days 15 days in solitary confinement is a human rights abuse. Now various other commentators have said that means it's torture. 15 days says the UN is the point at which people in solitary can begin to have irreparable psychological damage.
牢房往往比独自一人还要糟糕。所以，如果这本身不叫单独监禁，你也可以称之为一种二元监禁。把所有这些综合起来，有些人称之为酷刑。2011年，联合国酷刑问题特别报告员胡安·门德斯表示，在单独监禁中关押超过15天——
I don't actually like the 15-day standard. Some people fall apart in two days. And what Terry Cooper's calls torture happens in buildings specifically designed to maximize the isolation or, quote, unquote, segregation of prisoners for the duration of their time in the shoe. So if it is the ethical code of architects to promote human rights, what is their responsibility to the people who are incarcerated in their buildings? In Argentina, the military regime tortured people in a former auto body shop
我其实并不喜欢15天的标准。有些人两天就会崩溃。特里·库珀所说的酷刑发生在专门设计的建筑物中，这些建筑旨在最大限度地隔离囚犯，或者说在他们在“鞋子”里的这段时间里对他们进行所谓的“隔离”。因此，如果建筑师的职业伦理是促进人权，那么他们对被关押在他们所设计建筑中的人负有什么责任呢？在阿根廷，军政权在一个前汽车修理厂里对人实施酷刑，
that was one of their big torture centers. I'm not going to... nobody's going to say that the architects who designed the auto body shop are somehow responsible or even that the car mechanics, who just own it are. No, of course not. This is Rafael Sparry. But when solitary confinement is a practice that requires a certain kind of space, and when you're specifying the space exactly for that and making sure that all the doors can be operated without, you know, seeing another human being, that the outdoor space
那是他们的主要酷刑中心之一。我不会……没有人会说设计那个汽车修理厂的建筑师负有某种责任，甚至连拥有它的汽车修理工也不负有责任。不，当然不是。这是拉斐尔·斯帕里说的。但是，当单独监禁是一种需要某种特定空间的做法，当你确切地为该目的指定空间，并确保所有门都可以在不看到另一个人类的情况下操作，确保户外空间
is going to be one that's occupied by one person at a time, that there's nowhere for a group of people to actually be together. So it just won't happen. Then that is a design intent. When used as intended, human rights violations will result. Rafael Sparry is an architect here in San Francisco, and he's the president of a group called ADPSR. Architects, designers, and planners for social responsibility.
每次只由一个人占用，根本没有一群人能够真正聚在一起的地方。所以这一切都不会发生。那么这就是一种设计意图。当按预期使用时，就会导致侵犯人权的行为。拉斐尔·斯帕里是旧金山的一名建筑师，他是一个名为ADPSR（社会责任建筑师、设计师和规划师）的组织的负责人。
A few years back, Raphael had been following the news from Guantanamo Bay and reading up on mass incarceration in the US, not necessarily as an architect per se, just as a civic-minded social justice-oriented kind of guy. And then, one day in 2010, he saw an article in the San Francisco Chronicle about the redesign of San Quentin Prison in California. So yeah, the Chronicle actually ran a picture that was supplied by the Decrection's apartment that was the CAD model. A kind of three-dimensional floor plan of the execution chamber suite of rooms. And I was like, they're using the same tools that I use to make
几年前，拉斐尔一直在关注关塔那摩湾的新闻，并了解美国的大规模监禁情况，不一定是以建筑师的身份，而只是作为一个关心公民社会的、具有社会正义导向的人。然后，在2010年的一天，他在《旧金山纪事报》上看到了一篇文章，内容是关于加州圣昆廷监狱的改造。是的，《纪事报》确实刊登了一张由惩教部门提供的图片，那是CAD模型。一种执行室套房的三维平面图。当时我想，他们正在使用我用来为人们建造
residential additions for people to make schools. Only this project is going to kill people. That was totally shocking. Seeing the remodel of the death chamber was the catalyzed event, but you could argue that there's a difference between designing a death room and designing a shoe. But Sparry views both as immoral and in violation of the human rights that architects wear to uphold. Rafael Sparry wants architects and the profession of architecture as a whole, at least in the
住宅增建部分和学校的相同工具。只不过这个项目是要杀人。这太令人震惊了。看到死囚室的改造是一个催化事件，但你可以争辩说，设计死囚室和设计“鞋子”是有区别的。但斯帕里认为这两者都是不道德的，并且违反了建筑师发誓要维护的人权。拉斐尔·斯帕里希望建筑师以及整个建筑行业，至少在美国，
U.S., to stop building shoes or any structures that are designed for long-term solitary confinement or are designed to put people to death. He's not talking about all prisons or jails, just the ones where isolation is baked into the physical structure, like the AIA architect designed shoe at Pelican Bay Prison. Pelican Bay State Prison is way up in Northern California near the Oregon border, hours from any major city. It opened in 1989 to house the so-called worst of the worst, suspected gang members, and people who are seen to pose the greatest threat to officers and other inmates.
停止建造“鞋子”或任何旨在长期单独监禁或剥夺他人生命的结构。他并不是指所有的监狱或看守所，而只是指那些将隔离融入物理结构中的监狱，比如由AIA建筑师设计的位于鹈鹕湾监狱的“鞋子”单元。鹈鹕湾州立监狱位于北加州偏远地区，靠近俄勒冈州边境，距离任何主要城市都有数小时的车程。它于1989年开放，旨在关押所谓的“最危险中的最危险”分子、疑似黑帮成员以及被认为对警官和其他囚犯构成最大威胁的人。
It was modeled after a prison in Arizona and has since inspired design for other prisons across the country, even buildings in Guantanamo Bay. Life of the Law's Nancy Malaine head corrections officer, Lieutenant Rick Graves, describe his take on the purpose of the shoe when she visited Pelican Bay in 2012. The key to making this design work in our favor is not just the design of it, but how it's managed. And historically Pelican Bay has done a very good job of managing the worst of the worst in the state. This prison was designed and built to manage 5% of the California prison population. Those were the 5% that were causing the majority of crimes in the other prisons throughout the state. The way that Pelican Bay or any prison has managed is really the determining factor in what life is like for prisoners.
它是根据亚利桑那州的一所监狱为蓝本建造的，此后启发了全国各地其他监狱的设计，甚至包括关塔那摩湾的建筑。《法律的生活》节目的南希·马莱恩听取了惩教官里克·格雷夫斯中尉在她2012年参观鹈鹕湾时对“鞋子”目的的看法。使这种设计对我们有利的关键不仅在于其设计，还在于它是如何管理的。从历史上看，鹈鹕湾在管理该州最危险的罪犯方面做得非常好。这座监狱的设计和建造是为了管理加州5%的监狱人口。这5%的人引发了该州其他监狱中的绝大多数犯罪。鹈鹕湾或任何监狱的管理方式，才是决定囚犯生活状况的真正决定性因素。
The way these prisons are used isn't the only way they could be used. Prison management could decide that shoe prisoners could be allowed to go outside of the building in a security area, or the exercise yard could be repurposed as a communal dining hall. We're just making these up as far as I know these have never been considered. But for Rafael Sparry, the key here is design intent. Pelican Bay is managed the way it is, and prisoners day in, day out are the way they are, because that's how architects imagine the place to work during the design process.
这些监狱的使用方式并不是它们唯一的可能用法。监狱管理部门可以决定让“鞋子”单元的囚犯到建筑物外的安全区域活动，或者将运动场改造成公共餐厅。我们只是凭空想象这些，据我所知，这些方案从未被考虑过。但对拉斐尔·斯帕里来说，这里的关键在于设计意图。鹈鹕湾之所以按现在的方式管理，囚犯日复一日的生活之所以是这个样子，是因为建筑师在设计过程中就是这样想象这个地方的运作方式的。
And Sparry along with the ADPSR, architects, designers, and planners for social responsibility, say it's time to stop building the prisons that are designed for what he sees as solitary confinement or any other kind of torture or execution. It would seem like the least that architects could do would say to demonstrate our commitment to public health safety and well-being is to say, when you enter one of our buildings, it's not intended to kill you or torture you. Which brings us back to the rather minimal statement in the AIA Code of Ethics and Professional Conduct. Ethical Standard 1.4. Members should uphold human rights in all their professional endeavors.
斯帕里以及ADPSR（社会责任建筑师、设计师和规划师协会）表示，是时候停止建造那些旨在进行他所认为的单独监禁或任何其他形式的酷刑或处决的监狱了。建筑师能做的最基本的事情，为了证明我们对公众健康、安全和福祉的承诺，似乎就是说：当你进入我们的建筑时，它不是为了杀死你或折磨你。这就让我们回到了AIA《道德规范与职业行为准则》中那个相当简短的声明。伦理标准1.4。会员应在其所有的职业活动中维护人权。
That's it. Human rights refers to the international system that is built up around the United Nations and strongly supported by these advocacy organizations. Like Amnesty International and Human Rights Watch. Human rights is not a term that the United States courts use and it's not a term in the US Constitution. It actually refers to something even bigger than that. They said members should support the US Constitution that would be different. Sparry and the ADPSR are petitioning the AIA to adopt a new clause in its ethics code. Quote, members shall not design spaces intended for execution or for torture or other cruel
就是这样。人权指的是围绕联合国建立的并得到这些倡导组织强烈支持的国际体系。比如国际特赦组织和人权观察。人权不是美国法院使用的术语，也不是美国宪法中的术语。它实际上指的是比这更宏大的东西。他们说会员应该支持美国宪法，那将是另一回事。斯帕里和ADPSR正在向AIA请愿，要求在其道德规范中加入一项新条款。引述：“会员不得设计旨在用于处决、酷刑或其他残忍、不人道或有辱人格的待遇或处罚的空间，包括长期单独监禁。”
inhuman or degrading treatment or punishment, including prolonged solitary confinement. And so if you happen to find yourself in prison, you should know that because you're prison in design by an architect, you won't be subjected to cruel inhuman, degrading punishment or get killed there. So far, the San Francisco chapter of the AIA has recommended the proposal. We should point out here that the AIA San Francisco was instrumental in the creation of 99% of visible, but it doesn't give us any money or servant in the editorial function we run our own ship completely.
因此，如果你碰巧发现自己身处监狱，你应该知道，因为你的监狱是由建筑师设计的，你不会在那里遭受残忍、不人道、有辱人格的惩罚或被杀害。到目前为止，AIA旧金山分会已经推荐了这个提案。我们在这里应该指出，AIA旧金山分会对于“99%隐形”的创立起到了关键作用，但它没有给我们提供任何资金，也不参与我们的编辑工作，我们完全是独立运营的。
If the AIA National adopts this amendment, it will become part of the ethics code for all AIA architects, virtually every practicing architect in the United States. Regardless of how you feel about prisons, whether we should rehabilitate people or whether we should lock them up and throw away the key, it's important to keep in mind that these attitudes change over time. From around the 1890s to the 1950s, the US had a really different take on prison. The emphasis was on curing or rehabilitating people from a life of crime.
如果AIA全国委员会采纳了这项修正案，它将成为美国所有AIA建筑师（实际上是美国几乎每一位执业建筑师）道德规范的一部分。无论你对监狱有什么样的看法，无论我们是应该改造人们还是应该将他们关起来并扔掉钥匙，重要的是要记住这些态度随时间而改变。从1890年代到1950年代左右，美国对监狱有截然不同的看法。重点是治愈或改造人们，让他们脱离犯罪生涯。
Granted, there were some really terrible things that happened in prisons during that time, but the emphasis, at least, was on getting prisoners to become productive members of society again. A big shift happened with the war on drugs, which sent a lot more people to jail, and then there was the violence of the prison riots or uprisings that happened through the 1970s. So from the point of view of prison officials
诚然，在那段时间的监狱里确实发生了一些非常可怕的事情，但重点至少是让囚犯重新成为对社会有用的成员。随着打击毒品战争的爆发，发生了巨大的转变，这导致更多的人入狱，然后是贯穿20世纪70年代的监狱骚乱或暴动的暴力事件。因此，从负责关押这些群体的监狱官员的角度来看，
who were in charge of jailing these populations, locking people up in their cells for most of the time, started looking like a good option. Hence the shoe. But when you create a building with a very extreme design intent with little variability, you're locking prisoners into that current mindset for the lifespan of the prison. Tam's correctional center, a supermax prison in Illinois, was closed in early 2013 to make up for a state budget shortfall.
把人们大部分时间锁在牢房里，开始看起来是一个不错的选择。因此，“鞋子”单元应运而生。但是，当你创造一个具有极端设计意图且几乎没有可变性的建筑时，你就在监狱的整个生命周期中将囚犯锁定在当前的心态中。伊利诺伊州的超级监狱——塔姆惩教中心于2013年初关闭，以弥补该州的预算赤字。
It turns out housing a shoe prisoner is nearly twice as expensive as housing a general population inmate. Wide spread budgetary pressure and possibly the influence of anti-solitary confinement activists is also causing state governments to reduce the number of Supermax prisoners in Mississippi, Maine, and Colorado. Rafael Sparrow may find he has a strange and powerful ally in his fight to stop architects building Supermax prisons, and that is broke state governments. But even if Supermax facilities fall out of fashion, Sparrow says it's still important to establish ethical guidelines that distinguish architects as a profession. It's professional ethics that set a profession aside from other occupations.
事实证明，收容一个“鞋子”单元的囚犯的费用几乎是收容普通人口囚犯的两倍。广泛的预算压力以及反单独监禁活动人士的影响，也促使密西西比州、缅因州和科罗拉多州的州政府减少了超级监狱囚犯的数量。拉斐尔·斯帕里可能会发现，在他阻止建筑师建造超级监狱的斗争中，他有一个奇怪而强大的盟友，那就是破产的州政府。但即使超级监狱不再流行，斯帕里说，建立能够将建筑师作为一个专业群体区分开来的伦理准则仍然很重要。正是职业伦理将一个职业与其他职业区分开来。
When you join a licensed profession, your group has a monopoly to provide services in that sector. Not anybody else can be an architect. And in fact, one of AI's big activities is patrolling people who are holding themselves out as architects, but aren't actually architects. In exchange for the public monopoly that we get as a group, we as a group have to adopt professional ethics that put the public interest first. And the way that we do that is the way,
当你加入一个需要执照的行业时，你们的群体在该领域享有提供服务的垄断权。不是任何人都可以成为建筑师。事实上，AIA的主要活动之一就是打击那些自称为建筑师但实际上并非建筑师的人。作为我们作为一个群体获得的公共垄断权的交换，我们作为一个群体必须采用将公共利益放在首位的职业伦理。我们这样做的方式，
for instance, that doctors do that, is to say we're not gonna do anything to injure any of you intentionally. This episode of 99% Invisible is a special co-production with the podcast Life of the Law. You can hear their show at lifeofthelaw.org. This story was produced by Sam Greenspan, Nancy Malaine, Caitlin Prest, Julia Barton, Shannon Heffernon, Ashley Ann Craigbaum, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute
例如，就像医生们所做的那样，就是宣称我们绝不故意伤害你们任何人。本期“99%隐形”节目是与播客《法律的生活》合作的特别节目。你可以在lifeofthelaw.org收听他们的节目。这个故事由萨姆·格林斯潘、南希·马莱恩、凯特琳·普雷斯特、朱莉娅·巴顿、香农·赫费农、阿什利·安·克雷格鲍姆和我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW以及旧金山
of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars, but we have loads of more information and a link to life of the law at 99tapia.org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
美国建筑师学会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞本节目，我在推特上的账号是@Roman Mars，但我们有大量的信息以及指向《法律的生活》的链接，网址是99tapia.org。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。